brittany griner sentenced to nine years
in a russian prison we have to remember
that her lawyers had for the entirety of
the case had appealed for leniency from
this judge
and the stars are sharing their
emotional reactions on social media
viola davis simply wrote no words andy
cohen tweeted bring britney home and
jada pinkett smith pointed out the irony
of this sentencing coming alongside
another stunning update back home
the u.s federal government bringing
charges against four police officers
charged in the killing of briana taylor
that this act violated federal civil
rights laws
and that those violations
resulted in miss taylor's death
the red table talk host wrote in her
instagram story on the same day where we
finally got some justice for brianna i
find out that brittany griner just got
nine years in russia hashtag free
britney have you
thought of like what like if it was you
i was trying to imagine it and it's hard
for me to to even put myself
into what she's going through like she's
such a great human being
since brittany's arrest in february
she's received support from both
hollywood and the sports community at
the espy awards steph curry was one of
many athletes voicing their support the
nba star said we cannot stop believing
for her and we will not stop hoping for
the day we can welcome her home safely
so what's next for brittany her legal
team said she plans to appeal and the
biden administration is reiterating its
course of action she never should have
had to endure a trial in the first place
under president biden's direction the s
government continues to work
aggressively
pursuing every avenue
to bring home brittany as you all know
we have made a substantial offer to
bring her and paul whalen home
we urge russia to accept that proposal